on alias before we move on to the movie
on alias you get to do such cool stuff
you mean there's
aside from all of the really neat sort
of martial arts techniques that you get
to learn you also get to learn this
great sort of spy techniques on how to
hide and how to enter a room if there's
danger do you ever get to use that stuff
in real life well not so much like we
have a lot of conversations about how to
actually hold the gun do we hold the gun
like this do we hold the gun like this
do we swoop it up but that I haven't
used so much lately
I heard you carry a gun around just for
show right but no the the spy techniques
I did use actually at work because they
are very sneaky and sketchy about what's
coming up on the show you make the
writers and producers they they don't
want you to know and it's completely
closed off particularly to actors
particularly to me although you know
whatever they should let me know right I
mean I figured out panties I shouldn't
be able to know what there was a day
last year when I kind of you were a mine
for an hour very good actually but
there's a time when you snuck into the
room to see what the piss sneaked into
the room
snuck isn't a word Conan and you went to
Harvard and you should know that
[Applause]
you should know I went to the Harvard
driving school by teach me much there
but I can parallel park by the basket so
I have good what good good here yes so
you snuck into the room and I kind of
read everything that was on the board I
read everything I knew what the last
moment of the year was gonna be with the
first moment the next year was gonna be
and then I was kind of sneaking out and
I heard somebody walk by and I whipped
around and and hid for a minute and then
ran down the hall and of course I
totally forgot everything that I read so
the minute you heard somebody you like
we're up against the what what if you
had just gone into your show character
and karate chop them and then jam their
nose into their brain
there's a I'm sorry wait there's that I
keep a dictionary down here and I just
found it I just want to look Oh what the
hell look right here
snuck past and past part
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know I just realized you could kick
my ass no I don't want to mess with you
I just showed that clip and then I'm
like I'm gonna pick on her now I don't
want it now daredevil is this a good
would you say this is a good Valentine's
Day double is a chick flick like chick
flick yah yah sisterhood right practical
magic but no it's there no Jared yeah
all right all right and the whole cast
of the hours is in this movie I
understand and they all fight each other
to here that's a pretty amazing scene
Merrill's got a heck of no actually
daredevil is a really romantic movie
mm-hmm yeah it's it's um I mean I think
the girls will have to drag the guys to
see their dough no it's actually it's
really romantic and the cool thing about
it for women is that Elektra is
Daredevils equals she's not some damsel
in distress you know who help me she's
definitely oh they definitely got the
right woman to do these fight scenes cuz
they are
[Applause]